ام
اهلا بكم قالت مصادر امنيه عراقيه ان
مليشيا الحشد الشعبي سحبت عناصرها من
تكريت بعد ردود فعل شعبيه ورسميه على
الانفلات الامني الذي مارسته المليشيا في
المدينه من جهه اخرى قالت هيئه علماء
المسلمين في العراق ان القوات الحكوميه
قتلت سته عشر معتقلا اغلبهم من السنه في
سجن المصريه جنوبي العراق نتوقف بعد الخبر
لنناقشه في محورين ما الذي يفسر سماحه
ضلوع القوات العراقيه بارتكاب انتهاكات
طائفيه في تكريت وغيرها من مناطق العراق
فكيف ستنعكس هذه الانتهاكات على مستقبل
المواجهه بين القوات العراقيه ومقاتلي
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
في تصريح لهيئه علماء المسلمين في العراق
قالت الهيئه ان القوات الحكوميه المشرفه
على سجن مصيريه في محافظه ذي قار جنوبي
العراق قتلت بالصعق الكهربائي سته عشر
معتقلا غالبيتهم من السنه سكان مناطق جنوب
بغداد تصريح ياتي في خضم الحديث عن
انتهاكات منهجيه واسعه مارستها ميليشيا
الحشد الشعبي الشيعيه وعناصر من القوات
العراقيه في مدينه تكريت بعد استعادتها من
مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
ما كان يفترض ان تكون عمليه تحرير ل مدينه
تكريت تخلص اهلها من هيمنه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه اتضح انها كانت في احسن الاحوال
استبدال معاناه باخرى فبينما غرقت الحكومه
وانصارها في التحليل لاستعاده المدينه
كانت ميليشيات ما يسمى الحشد الشعبي وبعض
قواتها تعيث فسادا في مركز محافظه صلاح
الدين
اعدم كثيرون وسحلت جثثهم ومثل بها حسب
روايات شهود كما احرقت المليشيات المتاجره
ومنازل السكان بعد ان نهبتنا فيها ومما قد
يؤكد البعد الطائفي الدفين لعمليات
الانتقام ان الاستهداف طال في جانب كبير
من منازل ضباط كبار في الجيش العراقي
السابق
شاركوا في الحرب ضد ايران في المشهد ايضا
محنه متفاقمه لنحو خمسه الاف اسره تمنعها
القوات العراقيه والحشد الشعبي من العوده
الى منازلها التي نجحت منها في وقت سابق
الى مناطق الحويجه والرياض وسمراء وضع
ماساوي لم تدفع معه دعوه رئيس الوزراء
حيدر العبادي المسؤولين العسكريين
والامنيين الى الحفاظ على امن وسلامه
المواطنين
لوقف الانتهاكات وهي دعوه جاءت متاخره بعد
استغاثات السكان وانسحاب مجلس محافظه صلاح
الدين الى خارج قضاء تكريت احتجاجا على ما
سماها انتهاكات
ميليشيات السنه
كما تعالت من داخل البرلمان اصوات حذرت
العبادي وحكومته من ان تلك الجرائم ستقود
الانتصار على تنظيم الدوله شيوخ ووجهاء
عشائر تكريت
هددوا باللجوء الى المجتمع الدولي ل توفير
حمايه للمدنيين
وطالبوا محكمه العدل الدوليه بملاحقه
مرتكبي الانتهاكات
كمجرمي حرب بين ما اقرت حركه عصائب اهل
الحق وهي مشاركه في الحشد بوقوع فظاعات
وطالبت الحكومه ومواجهتها هيئه علماء
المسلمين في العراق حملت حكومه الاعداد
والجيش و من وصفتهم سياسيين رفضوا ان
يكونوا ادوات بيد اعداء العراق حملتهم
المسؤوليه عما اسمتها جرائم اباده جماعيه
وسياسه الارض المحروقه التي تقوم بها
ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي وفي سياق منفصل
اتهمت الهيئه القوات الحكوميه المشرفه على
سجن الناصريه جنوب العراق بقتل سته عشر
معتقلا غالبيتهم من سكان مناطق جنوب بغداد
السنه بالسعه الكهربائي
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفينا من بغداد
احمد الاسد عضو البرلمان العراقي عن
ائتلاف دوله القانون ومن اربيل الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وليد الزبيدي لكن وقبل اه
النقاش نستطلع الوضع في تكريت عبر الهاتف
من الصحفي في محافظه صلاح الدين علي سيد
علي اولا ما حقيقه انسحاب قوات الحشد
الشعبي من تكريت
اه تحيه طيبه لك ولضيوفك الكرام
الحقيقه انه اليوم بعد اجتماع محافظه صلاح
الدين في حكومه حكومه محافظه صلاح الدين
المحليه مع رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي
امر الاخير بانسحاب قوات الحزب الشعبي
ولكن ما تم تطبيقه على الارض حتى هذه
اللحظه هو انفصال الانسحاب بعض الفصائل
التابعه الى الحزب الشعبي من مدينه تكريت
الى خارجها لكن مازال تتواجد بعض الفصائل
التابعه للحزب الشعبيه في المدينه يعني
يفترض ان الشرطه المحليه والاتحاديه هي
التي تتولى زمام
الامور في في تكريت السؤال ما قدرتها فعلا
على السيطره على الوضع وتفيد هذه ال
المليشيا مستقبلا
اه الحقيقه من خلال ما راينا عن الفريقين
التفريق ان قوات الشرطه الاتحاديه التقرير
الشرطه صلاح الدين المحليين ليس لها قدره
او السلطه على عناصر الحزب الشعبي هذا ما
نراه على الارض
وبالتالي ما الضمانات لكي لا تعود هذه
الميليشيات في حال انها اه انسحبت الى
الوراء قليلا الى الى تكريت والسيطره على
الوضع مجددا
حتى هذه اللحظه لا توجد ايضا مناطق لم
تنظر
من قبل الجلوس وان كانت في الحكومه
المركزيه في بغداد او الحكومه المحليه في
بعدم بال بالمناسبه نعم المساحه
الان ولكن بامكانهم الدخول والخروج بحريه
انسحبوا الى الحدود الخارجيه للمدينه على
اطراف المدينه تكريه الجنوبيه قرب قريه
العوجه
من الناحيه ال ال اللوجيستيه وال العسكريه
والقتاليه ان صح التعبير هذه اه الشرطه
كيف كيف يفترض ان ان تستلم الامور الان
اه يجب ان تستخدم الامور طبعا بالتاكيد
بعد انسحاب الحزب الشعبي بشكل كامل اه
اضافه الى ملاحظه وقوات الشرطه المحليه لا
تمتلك القدره نعم لديهم العدد الكافي من
الجنود والمنتسبين لكن قدرتهم التسليحيه
ليست كامله بشكل كافي يمكن الدفاع على
المدينه في حال حدوث اي اختراق من قبلكم
اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات اه السيد علي
كاظم صحفي في محافظه صلاح الدين ناتي الان
الى اه نقاش السيد الاسدي هذه الانتهاكات
والانفلاتات سبق التحذير منها قبل معركه
تكريت ولكنها تحصل الان اه لماذا اه اه اه
لم تنجح الحكومه في التوقي منها وفي منعها
نعم بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم في الواقع
الامر الاول الذي يريد ان اؤكده ان الحشد
الشعبي هو ليست مليشيات منفلته او خارجه
على القانون وانما هو مؤسسه عسكريه تتبع
للحكومه وللدوله العراقيه والتي توجيهات
السيد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
يعني
للمعلومه يعني للمعلومه هي تشكلت بفتوى
دينيه
استجابه الشعب للانخراط في الحشد الشعبي
كان وفقا لفتوى المرجعيه ولكنها شكلت بامر
الديوان من القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
وموافقه مجلس الوزراء الذي يضم كل الوزراء
الذين يمثلون كل الشعب العراقي وبالتالي
هي رسميه وموافق عليها في مجلس الوزراء
والمصادقه عليها او تعمل تحت غطاء الدوله
لذلك تسميتها بالميليشيات هو امر
حتى في هذه الحاله يعني اذا تحدثنا ان
تتقرب انها اصبحت رسميه ونظاميه يعني
المساله اصبحت اه اه يعني ربما اصعب بكثير
كيف انها رسميه وترتكب مثل هذه الانتهاكات
انت انت تتحدث عن انتهاكات ليس لها وجود
في الواقع ما اظهره تقريركم منصور هو
عباره عن ما نتج من معارك تكريت خاض فيها
الحشد الشعبي والقوات المسلحه معارك
ابتدات من اليوم احداش ثلاثه
واستمرت لمده ثلاثه او اربعه ايام ثم بدات
وثيرتها بالتباطؤ لتعود مجددا في يوم
الخميس الماضي وتستمر على مدار سته ايام
شارك فيها طيران التحالف ضربات جويه
لمختلف القواطع في تكريت واستخدمت الاسلحه
الثقيله والمتوسطه
واسلحه الصواريخ وكل الاسلحه المتوفين
للجيش العراقي والحديث الشعبي من اجل
انزال اه اه ضربات موجعه القيادات ومقرات
سيطره الداعش حتى يتمكن من تحديد التكريم
لذلك الصور التي ظهرت في التقرير اكثرها
ان لم تكن جميعها هي عباره عن حرائق و
ناتج من
لاحظنا بدقه ان البيوت مهدمه وهي تحترق
الاسد
هذا ال المساله اشمل من هذا يعني ليست لها
تحديدا علاقه بالتقرير التقرير يقدم ال
الخبر
ويحاول ان اه اه يجمع كل المعلومات
المتعلقه ولكن ولكن الاعتراف بها كانت
الاعتراف بهذه الانتهاكات اعترافات رسميه
يعني جاءت حتى على لسان السيد رئيس
الحكومه اه اه العبيدي وكالات الانباء
ومنها الى مثل هذه الانتهاكات ال التحالف
ايضا هدد بوقف اه اه يعني غاراته هدد بوقف
في غابه اذا لم ينسحب الحشد الشعبي ثم عاد
بعد هذا الانسحاب يعني هذه جمله اعترافات
بوجود
يرتكبه ربما ممارساتها بنظامها
لا يعني ان التحالف الدولي بانسحابها
وعودته فيما تتحدث عنه من الاوامر التي
اصدرها رئيس الوزراء رئيس الوزراء يتعامل
مع قضايا تصل اليه تقارير وبالتالي هو
يصدر احكاما حتى يمنع حدوث مثل هذه
القضايا او تكرارها ان حدثت اما لماذا لا
تذكر محافظ تصريح السيد محافظه صلاح الدين
اليوم الذي اكد فيه ان ما اشيع ونقلها في
وكالات الانباء يتنافى كثيرا مع الواقع
على الارض هذا اليوم كانت جوله كثير من
وسائل الاعلام بما فيها ثمانيه من وكالات
الانباء الاجنبيه ويتجول في تكريت وفي كل
شوارع ومناطق تكريت
باعتباركم غادر والمحافظه اه سيد الاسدي
اليس هذا صحيحا لم ترتكب بالنهايه
انتهاكات
هذا ليس صحيحا هذا هذا هذا ليس صحيح حسب
بمغادره المحافظ هنالك شجاري يبدو حصل بين
حمايه المحافظه بعض الاخوه المتواجدين
هناك
المغادره الشارع وليس مغادره محافظ هذه
المحافظ معنا بكل تفاصيل العمليه سيد
الزبيدي اه اذن اه السيد الاسدي ينكر وجود
اي
انتهاكات في في تكريت وهذا الحشد الشعبي
هو جزء من المنظومه
الامنيه يعني كيف تقيم انت مدى استجابه
الحكومه لمنع مثل هذه التجاوزات وهذه
الانتهاكات الحاصله وال وال مؤكده يعني
معترف بها حسب شهود عيان حسب اخبار وحتى
حسب تصريحات رسميه يعني رئيس الحكومه لم
ينكرها قال هناك تجاوزات اه حصلت فيها في
في تكريت
لا ندخل بحوار سجالي مع ضيفك في من بغداد
ولكن الاهم اننا دخلنا اخطر مرحله من
تداعيات الاحتلال الامريكي في العراق بعد
عام الفين وثلاثه
واخطر نتائج هذا الاحتلال تمثل بادواته من
العمليه السياسيه والحكومات المتعاقبه
ابتداءا من حكومه علاوي مرورا بالجعفري
والمالكي والان العبادي اه الامر لا يحتاج
الى تاكيد ليست المعركه اه الاولى التي
تحصل في تكريت اه حصلت في جرف الصخر وحصل
تشبه اباده جماعيه في ديالا وفي يسرب وفي
مناطق كثيره ارتكب الحشد والجيش ايضا اه
حقيقه كثير من الفضاعات وليس خروقات ولكن
الاهم من هذا اه في العراق كيف يمكن ان
نتجاوز هذه المحنه هذه محنه مخطط لها وكما
تفضلت م ب اه م قدمت كمانها اه ممنهجه
عندما تكون منهج
هذا البرنامج
دعني اسال هنا يعني هذه المساله هي عدم
قدره ام عدم وجود اراده سياسيه لكبح جماح
هذه الميليشيات
ابدا موجود مخطط للاسف المخطط يعني خارج
معروف اه نحن الان وصلنا الى النقطه
الاخطر وهي اثاره الفتنه الطائفيه مناطقيا
وهذه طبعا حصلت بادوات اه الاجهزه الامنيه
وعندما يقول ضيفك اه الاخ من بغداد بان
هذه مؤسسه رسميه هذا يعني ان رئيس الوزراء
العبادي اه يعرف تماما ما يحصل وسيحصل
وعليه فان المجتمع الدولي مطالب بان تحصل
محاكمه الجرائم التي حصلت كما حصل في
السياقات في العالم مثل رواندا حيث حكم
وسطاش الف واحد بجرائم حرب وعدم الكثير
منهم اه لماذا هذه المحاكمات يجب ان تكون
نحن مجتمع عشائري والمجتمع العشائري سيبقى
محتقن كلما توجهنا رسائل
ذهبوا بعيدا ولا يحتقن وهذا لا يمكن خسروا
اموالهم وبيوتهم ونساؤهم وكل شيء فعليه
هذا الاحتقان اه ينذر بخطوره كبرى بتفجير
المجتمع العراقي العمليه السياسيه
والحكومات المتعاقبه وكل السياسيين
والعاملين في مؤسسات الحكومه اقصد الكبار
يريدون هذا التفجير الصراع الطائفي في
العراق من مصالحهم ول من يامرهم من خارج
العراق سواء كان الولايات المتحده او
غيرها واه الامر يجب ان يكون اوسع واكبر
من ان نكون ردود فعل اه ذاتيه وعاطفيه على
هذه الجرائم العراقيين قد يتحمل الكثير اه
بسبب ما يخسره الان ولكن يجب ان يكون هناك
امر حاسم ودقيق اه ان تتدخل الا يتدخل
المجتمع الدولي لكي يحاسب الحكومه التي
تشرف على كل المؤسسات التي ترتكب هذه
الفضائح في المناطق هذه مناطق كثيره ايضا
ال الامر الاخطر ان كل ما يحصل بعيدا عن
وسائل الاعلام المحايده ولا يسمحوا الا
المراسلين يعملون ضمن
والاحزاب والمؤسسات الاعلاميه للاتصال هذه
السلطه السيد الاسدي دعنا نرجع الى السؤال
المركزي الذي بدا يطرح منذ الارهاصات
الاولى لمعركه تكريت ما الحاجه اصلا اساسا
الى هذا الحشد الشعبي الم يكن الجيش
العراقي اه اه يعني قادرا على حسم هذه
المعركه بمفرده لماذا لا بد من من تجيش
اطراف اخرى غير نظمها
نعم انا اه قبل ان اجيب على سؤالك اشاره
سريعه لل ضيفك الكريم فيما يتعلق بوسائل
الاعلام كان باستطاعه تشكيلات الحشد
الشعبي عمليات صلاح الدين والقوات المسلحه
المتجه الى معها ان تمنع دخول اي وسيله من
وسائل الاعلام لو كان هنالك عملا ومنهجا
لما اه اشيع وما نقل وما حدث ولكن سمحنا
ومنذ اليوم الاول بدخول كل وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه والعربيه والعراقيه
لتشاهدو توثق كل ما يحصل لاننا كنا
مطمئنون ولا واعيدوا اؤكد انني ما ذكرته
في بدايه حديثي لا يعني انه لم تحصل هنالك
اي مخالفات نعم حصلت بعض المخالفات ولكنها
حسبنا عليها نحن والجيش وكل الاجهزه
الامنيه و تابعناها بدقه ونعمل على ملاحقه
كل من قام بها لاننا نرفض قطعا مثل هذه
الممارسات التي تحصل بشكل فردي اعود الى
سؤالك ما يتعلق بالجيش العراقي اه كما
تعلم ويعلم الجميع الانهيارات التي حصلت
في بدايه شهر حزيران من العام الماضي
والتي اه كانت ورافقتها انهيار الجيش
والوحدات العسكريه في الموصل وفي تكريت
بحيث اننا فقدنا خلال ايام قليله محافظتين
بكل اقضيتها ونواحيها سبب انكسارا كبيرا
في معنويات هذا الجيش وسبب انهيارات اه
كانت تهدد العاصمه نفسها بالخطر مما
استدعى المرجعيه الدينيه و شعور بالخطر
الكبير ان تصدر فتواه الشهيره وان يتقدم
كل العراقيين من كل الطوائف والمناطق
والاديان
الى في الدفاع عن العراق الحاجه كانت الى
العدد الى ان نوعي يعني ال ال اضافه عدديه
ام نوعيه بالنسبه لهذا الحزب
لا هو في الواقع اضافه نوعيه اكثر منه
اضافه عدديه لاننا من خلال الفتره التي
اصدرتها المرجعيه ومن خلال اخوه كل ابناء
الشعب العراقي تقدم للانخراط في هذه
الهيئه وفي هذه التشكيلات الذين يعتقدون
بضروره الدفاع عن العراق
وارضه التي استبيحت في نينوى وفي تكريت
وفي كل ما السؤال المنطقه اكثر الاسد
لماذا لم يقع اللجوء الى اه يعني تحشيد
الناس في هذه المحافظات المعنيه
بالتاكيد هذا ما حدث ذلك من القضايا التي
ميزت عمليات بيك يا رسول الله التي حررت
شرق اه نهر دجله في تكريس ثم انطلقت
التحرر المنطقه الغربيه هو مركز مدينه
تكريت شاركت فيها و بشكل فاعل ومؤثر ابناء
العشائر ابناء محافظه صلاح الدين لدينا
اكثر من
اربعه او اربعه الاف وخمسمائه مقاتل من
ابناء محافظه صلاح الدين هم جزء من
تشكيلات الحديث الشعبي وعندما دخلنا الى
تكريت كانت اه حوالي ثلاثه تشكيلات من
ابناء محافظه تكريت
دعني انتقل الى السيد اه جديد سيدي كيف
تفهم هذا الاصرار على تشكيل هذه
الميليشيات ثم
وضمها الى ما يسمى بال منظومه ال ال
الامنيه ثم ما ما ما يعني هذه الانتهاكات
التي تتكرر ليس فقط في تكريت يعني هيئه
علماء المسلمين اه تحدثت عن سته عشر معتقل
في السجن اه المصيريه اه اه قتلوا اه
يعني كيف يمكن وضع كل هذه الممارسات في
سله واحده
عندما تاسس ال عفوا الجيش العراقي
والاجهزه الامنيه وكانت ما يسمى بال دمج
المليشيات في عام الفين وثلاثه
اه كانت النتيجه في الموصل وانهار الجيش
بشكل كامل من اول ضربه بسيطه الان لا اه
ليست تجربه دمج ميليشيات قليله وانما الان
الميليشيات اضعاف الجيش نحن مقبلون على
دوله ميليشيات ام على دوله اه حكم اه
رشيده وصحيحه اعتقد بخلاف ذلك ولهذا ما
يحصل في العراق اه لا يمكن ان ينطبق عليه
اي اه اه شرط او اي معالم معالم الدوله
الصحيحه اه تفضلت تذكر سطاشر اعدموا في
الناصريه في السجن وهم عجز المعتقلين هناك
الاف اعدموا وقتلوا تحت التعذيب في سجون
الجيش وغيرها خمسمائه وخمسين اه سجن في
العراق نساء وغير ذلك اه لا يوجد حكم صحيح
في العراق وسليم ولا توجد الا الممارسات
التي اصبحت التوافق منها هو ال النذر
اليسير وهذه جرائم وفظاعات في العراق تحصل
عليه فان المجتمع الدولي مطالب بان يضع
حدا لهذه
توقف هذه الحكومه والحكومات السابقه
ويحاسب الجديد الجميع على جرائم دعنا
نتوقف اه عند فاصل قصير نعود بعده لنقاش
ابقو معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها الانتهاكات المنهجيه التي
تمارسها القوات الحكوميه العراقيه
ومليشيات الحزب الشعبي ضد العرب السنه في
العراق السيد الاسدي يعني هذه الانتهاكات
في في تكريت ومساحه منها من رائحه الى حد
الان الا الا يرسل برساله خاطئه جدا لمن
ترون انه الظهير وس والسند لكم في معارك
التحرير المقبله واذكر هنا معركه الموصل
نعم بالتاكيد هي رساله سلبيه
حاولت وسائل الاعلام التي لم تتعامل مع
الخبر بالمهنيه ارسالها الى هذه الاطراف
ولكننا مطمئنون لامر واحد ان شركائنا كما
ذكرت هم شركاؤنا في التحرير وفي القتال
وفي الدفاع عن الوطن وفي تحرير المدن هم
حاضرون معنا يرون ويسمعون
يصفون شهداء هم كمان شهدائنا و يحتضنون مع
الارض كما نحتضنها وبالتالي هم من س ينقل
الى اهالي الموصل واهالي المدن والمناطق
الحقيقه التي حاول البعض طمسها انا اتحدث
عن مدينه تكريت لم نذهب اليها بنزهه وانما
دخلنا هاب معركه شرسه وكانت نتيجتها قليل
من الدخان وكثير من الدماء التي سالت وروى
هذه المدينه من اجل التحرير ولكن
يعني انت تقول تقول تقول ان هذه المعركه
اه شرسه جدا ولكن وزير الدفاع العراقي
نفسه والسيد خالد العبيدي يعني يتحدث عن
اربعمائه مقاتل من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
في تكريت يعني القصه مئات هل هل تحتاج ان
يحشد لها كل هذا الحشد
اولا معركه تكريت استمرت من يوم حداعش
حينما حدثت مجزره سبايكر
واقتيد الضحايا الاسبقيه التكريه المحتله
ومنذ ذلك التاريخ تقدمنا وحررنا سبايكر و
حافظنا عليها ثم تقدمنا من سامراء وصولا
الى جامعه صلاح الدين وبقيت التكليف مطوقه
من ثلاثه جهات مربعنا تطلع وكانت معارك
استنزاف مستمره ثم جاءت المعركه الاخيره
وكما ذكرت الاربعه ال الوقت
اربعمائه مقاتل في في مدينه ومحصله بقيه
دقيقه تحتاج والذين
الدقيقه اخر بقليل المتحصنين في السيد
الزبيدي الان يعني كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذه
المعادله بين مواجهه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه و احتمال حصول انتهاكات وال في
اجنده الحكومه العراقيه معارك قادمه
انا اعتقد لو تنظيم الدوله وعشرات
الفضائيات وعشرات الصحف وغير ذلك للترويج
لافكاره وطروحاته وما يتبناه من اه اه
خطاب للدفاع عن اهل السنه اه كما اه
يتضمنه هذا الخطاب لم انجح كما حصل في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليه وبعد ذلك انسحب
وحصلت فيها انجازا وفظاعات كبيره لان الان
الناس يتحدثون اه بامور كثيره من بينها ما
تفضلت به في سؤالكم الذي سيحصل من سيقف مع
الحشد من يقف مع الحكومه اه ماهي نتائج اه
في حال سيطره الجيش ومعه الحجم ومن معهم
ايضا وصحوات وغير ذلك ضمن نفس السياق و
نفس الاتجاه على هذه المناطق هم في بدايه
المعركه يقتلون ويسحلون كما ورد رويترز
في اه اه السبت معكم في الجزيره انهم
شاهدوا اه ساحل الناس في ال ال المراسلون
وتحدثت ضيفك عنهم انا اعتقد بان تنظيم
الدوله نجح نجاح كبير اه في اه اه يعني
مخاطبه اتباعه او مناطقه ومعهم حوارنا بان
من سياتي الى هذه المناطق سيستمر في حرق
منازلهم وتفجيرها ومزارعهم وقت لابنائهم
هذا هم غير مسيطرين وهناك خوف من ان تكون
هجمات عليهم فالناس يتساءلون كيف اذا سيطر
اه اقطاب العمليه السياسيه من السنه وغير
السنه وكيف سيطرت الشرطه وكيف سيكون هناك
حجم ما حجم الانتقام والثار اه من هذه
المناطق التي كثيره اشكر الوضع اعتقد خطير
والمعالجات تحتاج الى وقفه اكثر من اه
وقفه جاده وحقيقيه
شكرا لك السيد وليد الزبيدي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي من اربيل اشكر السيد احمد
الاسدي عضو البرلمان العراقي عن ائتلاف
دوله القانون من بغداد بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما اعتبرنا التقرير الله
قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد دمتم
بخير
ام